supongamos que tenemos el siguiente
conjunto de números tenemos 12 tenemos
33 tenemos 24 y también tenemos un 10 lo
que queremos hacer es encontrar
aproximadamente donde están distribuidos
estos números queremos encontrar más o
menos la mitad de todo este conjunto de
números en otras palabras queremos
encontrar un número que lo represente
bien y eso nos va a dar más o menos la
idea de aproximadamente donde están
distribuidos vamos a llamarle promedio a
esta tendencia central que queremos
encontrar para este conjunto de números
lo voy a poner por aquí el promedio de
este conjunto de números es muy probable
y de hecho estoy casi seguro de que has
escuchado la palabra promedio antes pero
vamos a entrar un poco más en detalles
acerca de los diferentes tipos de
promedio que existen el primer promedio
que vamos a ver se llama la media
aritmética seguro ya has escuchado
hablar de este promedio pero no por ese
nombre es el promedio más famoso que
existe voy a escribir por aquí media
aritmética y en qué consiste este
promedio y pues literalmente tomamos
nuestro conjunto de números sumamos
todos ellos y el resultado lo dividimos
entre la cantidad de números que
y entonces para este conjunto de números
tenemos que sumar 2 con 3 con 3 con 3
con 4 con 4 y con 10 y hay que dividirlo
entre la cantidad de números que son 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 números todo eso hay que
dividirlo entre 7 vamos a ver cuánto de
esta suma es 2 a eso hay que sumarle 9
que es 11 y luego hay que sumarle otros
8 que son 19 y lo hay que sumarle 10 que
son 29 entonces esto de aquí es igual a
29 séptimos simplificando un poco esta
fracción lo voy a poner por aquí es 4
con un séptimo si sacamos la calculadora
podríamos encontrar los decimales pero
bueno vamos a ver porque es una
representación de la tendencia central
de estos números si nos damos cuenta
tiene sentido cuatro y un séptimo es
ligeramente mayor que cuatro está
relativamente cerca de los números que
están como a la mitad de la lista y
bueno también podríamos decir que está
un poquito desviado hacia la derecha
pero tiene que ver con este 10 que es
mucho más grande que los dos números es
un valor extremo que desvía
la media aritmética entonces bueno hay
otros tipos de promedios casi siempre la
gente se refiere a la media aritmética
cuando dice el promedio y ya no hablan
acerca de nada más pero hay otros más
vamos aquí abajo a poner otro el segundo
que vamos a estudiar es la mediana la
mediana literalmente es agarrar el
número que está a la mitad es el número
que está a la mitad de nuestro conjunto
de números puede ser que a la mitad no
haya un número sino dos en este caso
para encontrar la mediana tenemos que
encontrar el promedio de esos dos
números vamos a calcular la mediana de
nuestro conjunto para esto déjenme
copiarlos aquí abajo tenemos un 2
tenemos un 3 un 3 un 3 14 otro 4 y un 10
ahora aquí hay 7 números si nos vamos de
izquierda a derecha 3 lugares y marcamos
aquí y nos vamos de derecha a izquierda
3 lugares y marcamos aquí nos damos
cuenta que el 3 está en medio de esos
números
simplemente escribimos los números en
orden y dije ah mira 3 es el número que
está a la derecha en el cuarto lugar y a
la izquierda en el cuarto lugar 13 es el
número que está justo a la mitad de
nuestro conjunto de números entonces la
mediana de nuestra muestra es 3
entonces 3 va a ser nuestro promedio
también tiene sentido es vamos a ver
otra vez el conjunto de números de acá y
pues si representa más o menos la
tendencia central ahora para aclarar un
poco las cosas aquí como teníamos una
cantidad impar de números había un
número justo a la mitad
esto no va a pasar siempre no siempre va
a ser tan fácil calcular esto qué pasa
si tuviéramos una cantidad par de
números por ejemplo como en el conjunto
dos tres cuatro o cinco supongamos que
ese es nuestro conjunto de números
entonces aquí no hay no hay un número
que sea la mitad el 3 está más cerca de
la izquierda el 4 está más cerca de la
derecha y entonces no podemos decidirnos
por uno único que esté a la mitad de la
lista aquí tenemos que hacer otra cosa
lo que vamos a hacer es considerar a los
dos como los números del medio pero
además tenemos que sacarles la media
aritmética es decir tenemos que sumarlos
y dividirlos entre dos es decir vamos a
hacer la cuenta por aquí abajo la media
va a ser 3 + 4 entre 2
que es 3.5 y entonces para este ejemplo
la mediana es 3.5 vamos a ver este
conjunto de datos un poquito más vamos a
ver esta esta muestra de aquí entonces
si nos fijamos en esta muestra vamos a
encontrar que la media aritmética
coincide con la mediana vamos a hacer
las cuentas vamos a calcular lo cual es
la media aritmética de este conjunto de
números es dos más tres más 45 que 54
queda 9 y 5 dan 14 entonces hasta aquí
es igual a 14 y eso hay que dividirlo
entre 4 entre 4 y cuánto es 14 cuartos
pues es 14 entre 4 estrés y sobran dos
cuartos o sea 13 un medio que es lo
mismo que 3.5 entonces en esta muestra
coincidieron la mediana y la media
aritmética en nuestra muestra original
no pasa esto la mediana es 3 mientras
que la media aritmética es 4 con un
séptimo y por qué pasa eso pensemos un
poquito por qué pasa eso tiene que ver
con el 10
casi todos estos números están muy cerca
entre ellos
y están muy cerca entre ellos y están
muy cerca de la media aritmética o de la
mediana pero este 10 está muy alejado es
un valor extremo lo voy a poner por aquí
es un valor extremo y lo que hace es
desviar la muestra es un valor tan
grande que queda muy alejado de los
otros números que hace que la media
aritmética se haga mucho más grande de
lo que pensábamos
es una cosa en la cual hay que pensar
cuando queremos saber qué promedio
queremos usar tenemos que ver que no
haya valores extremos porque si los
hubiera no podemos usar la media
aritmética en muchos otros casos la
mediana va a tener mucho más sentido
porque tenemos un número muy muy grande
que desvía que desvía la muestra de
números imaginemos que después del 10 le
agregamos a la muestra un millón
entonces si tuviéramos un millón en este
conjunto de datos al calcular la media
aritmética nos va a quedar un número muy
grande del orden más o menos de un
millón entre 8 que es mucho más grande
que casi todos estos números pero la
mediana todavía funciona la mediana va a
ser más o menos 3.5
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 entonces hay 2 números
en medio y la mediana sería 3.5 y
entonces es un poco menos susceptible un
poco menos sensible a uno o dos números
que son valores extremos vamos al último
tipo de promedio del cual vamos a hablar
que es la moda lo ve por aquí poner por
aquí es la moda esto no tiene nada que
ver con ropa y zapatos la moda
literalmente es tomarse el número que se
repita más veces es decir el número más
frecuente sale entonces es el número más
frecuente del conjunto de datos en
nuestro ejemplo es muy claro cuál es el
número más frecuente tenemos 12 tenemos
33 es tenemos 24 un 10 y bueno si
tenemos el 1.000.000 tenemos un millón
pero el número que más se repite es el 3
porque aparece 3 veces
entonces la moda es 3 una vez más la
moda parece ser una buena medida de
tendencia central porque se acerca a
muchos de los números que tenemos en
nuestro conjunto de datos la moda es un
poco truculento no va a saber que la
usen mucho porque casi siempre se vuelve
un poco ambiguo o bueno
ocasiones en las cuales mandamos acá por
ejemplo 2 3 4 y 5 ahí cuál sería la moda
pues no podemos decirlo todos los
números aparecen la misma cantidad de
veces entonces en una situación como
éstas pues vamos a evitar usar la moda y
en vez de eso vamos a utilizar otro
promedio como la mediana o como la media
aritmética ahora si realmente tenemos
números en los cuales uno de dómine
mucho a los otros entonces la moda si
parece ser un mejor indicador espero que
esto te haya dado una idea mejor de cómo
calcular un promedio o una tendencia
central lo voy a escribir por aquí
tendencia tendencia central de un
conjunto de números es un nombre
rimbombante pero simplemente está
diciendo con un número quiero
representar todo un conjunto de números
y para qué hacemos esto si sólo tenemos
siete números pero en vez de siete
podríamos tener siete millones o siete
mil millones
sería muy desgastante enseñárselos a
alguien simplemente queremos enseñarles
más o menos cómo están distribuidos en
promedio como ya dijimos la media
aritmética es lo que se utiliza más
frecuentemente pero es muy susceptible a
valores extremos en casos como estos es
mejor utilizar otras medidas de promedio
como la mediana